I have some very uh interesting
information I want to share with you on
a home remedy to lower the risk of
hypertension now what's fascinating
about hypertension is that 95% of all
hypertension is called essential
hypertension or it's called primary
hypertension or it's called idiopathic
hypertension all that means the same
thing unknown cause they don't know what
causes it I mean that is so bizarre to
me 95% of all hypertension is just an
unknown cause after all these years we
don't know what causes it of course we
do know how to treat it though right we
do know how to treat it with medication
so today I'm going to share with you
what I think is the true root cause of
hypertension and so you can very easily
uh deal with it in a natural way and I'm
going to show you an amazing technique
to drop your blood pressure if you have
high blood pressure within minutes and
it's very very cheap in fact it will
cost you nothing wait till you hear how
utterly simple this is okay but first I
need to share with you what causes um
the blood pressure to go higher or lower
there's certain receptors in your
arteries called Barrel receptors okay
and you have this whole uh connection
with the nervous system that goes right
up into the brain stem and the barrel
receptors are the things inside the
arteries or veins that pick up
information and they send it to the
nervous system and this whole thing is
controlled uh by What's called the
autonomic nervous system where you have
the sympathetic and the parasympathetic
you see when we look at blood pressure
we're dealing with systolic which is the
maximum pressure of contraction and then
diastolic is the minimum amount of
pressure in the relaxation phase in the
cardiac cycle and normally the systolic
should be 120 and the diastolic should
be 80 in a normal person at rest but of
course that's just average right it can
vary depending on a lot of different
factors
when it gets to the point of like 140
over 90 or more it becomes hypertension
so what can go wrong with this Barrel
receptor well the first thing that can
go wrong is a problem with the
electrolytes that control this receptor
and primarily I'm talking about sodium
and potassium Okay now what's
interesting about what most people are
told about high blood pressure is that
they must reduce the amount of sodium
but when you start having a sodium
deficiency that starts to create
dysfunction within the barrel receptor
so yes you're going to retain less fluid
right maybe drop the pressure but you're
going to create problems within the
barrel receptor and activate the
sympathetic nervous system and guess
what happens when you activate the
sympathetic nervous system the pressure
goes up so a lows salt diet can actually
worsen your blood pressure on the flip
side of that if we take the opposite
mineral potassium and we go up with
pottassium
boy do you create a really cool change
with your blood pressure I really
believe that potassium is one of the key
factors to help restoring blood pressure
not decreasing sodium just increasing
potassium and having sufficient amount
of sodium because we need a lot of
potassium we need like 4,700 milligrams
of potassium every single day and very
few people get that much you would have
to consume minimally seven to 10 cups of
vegetables like salad per day to get
even CL close to that 4700 Mig but the
point is that it's more important to
increase potassium than it is to lower
sodium and if you just look at the
conditions of a potassium deficiency
which is called hypoc calmia look at one
of the big side effects hypertension and
the next point I want to make is with
vitamin D now vitamin D is very
important in restoring problems with
your autonomic nervous system and so
many people that have hypertension
especially essential
hypertension unknown cause usually
either have a potassium deficiency or a
vitamin D deficiency and so just by
taking vitamin D that might solve your
problem right there oh and one more
important point I forgot to mention
about this sodium if someone is
deficient in sodium not only do they get
a spike in the sympathetic nervous
system but they create a weakness or
deficiency in the parasympathetic
nervous system so this is why it's so
important if you're trying to correct
hypertension not to just focus on
lowering your sodium in fact this is
just not something I just made up I'm
getting this from some pretty uh
interesting data and I'm going to put
that scientific data down below all
right so this next piece of the puzzle
gets even more interesting could it be
that insulin is one of the primary
Regulators of your Barrel receptors
because there's even certain therapies
that they will give you insulin to lower
your blood pressure now what's going on
with that I thought insulin was so bad
for you and Insulin creates hypertension
and metabolic syndrome and all these
other things well it does sort of but
here's what happens when you have a
spike of insulin you create insulin
resistance insulin resistance is
actually a deficiency of insulin insulin
resistance blocks your ability to use
insulin because just think about insulin
resistance in general it is at the heart
of metabolic syndrome which is a
combination of
hypertension high blood
glucose fatty liver and abnormal high
levels of lipids right like LDL and
things like that so we have this insulin
resistance High correlation connection
with hypertension especially essential
hypertension okay and I'm going to put
some data down below to validate that
remember that unknown cause I mean think
about if that was broadly promoted you'd
have to get people off sugar
carbohydrates you'd have to get people
on a low carb diet but they're not going
to do that because there's too much
money in carbohydrates and sugar and
these refined sugars and refined
carbohydrates deplete you of potassium
So based on what I just told you right
now increase your potassium more
vegetables go on a low carb diet take
vitamin D or get more sun okay that
should help you right there but I need
to show you something a very simple
thing that you can do right now to lower
your blood pressure and just try it out
it will work and it's simply changing
the way you breathe okay I mean it's so
simple we are going to do what's called
paste breathing and we're going to slow
down our breaths to six breaths per
minute now what's so special about this
six breaths per minute well apparently
that frequency of breathing is
synchronized with this Barrel receptor
in a way that is going to bring your
pressure down and the data on this
specifically the research this method of
breathing is going to significantly
reduce your blood pressure especially in
people with cardiac heart failure it has
the ability to increase oxygen
saturation increase exercise tolerance
give you more endurance with exercise
and on top of all that it's one of the
best things to decrease the sympathetic
nervous system that sympathetic
overdrive that fight ORF flight
dominance that so many people have
simply by practicing this method of
breathing I mean it's cheap it's fast
it's something anyone can do and if you
ever noticed people with hypertension or
especially if they have diabetes or
they're overweight they're not breathing
at six breaths per minute I mean they
are breathing pretty rapidly and this is
not something you'd have to do
constantly but just periodically during
the day while you're driving or you're
at home just start practicing these
breaths now here's how you would do it
okay you don't necessarily want to
breathe through your stomach for this
one you want to breathe through the
chest okay and you don't want to strain
or try to do it with a lot of effort
because you're going to activate the
sympathetic nervous system you want to
slowly just breathe through your nose
and I'll just
demonstrate
slowly breathe into your chest it's a
5-second inhalation slowly and then a
5-second exhalation all right so that's
how you would do it and that will give
you six complete breathing cycles per
minute which will synchronize to this
barel receptor and start affecting your
autonomic nervous system and bringing
your pressure down your pulse rate will
come down and you'll feel very calm now
because of the censoring and the
suppressing of the algorithms on YouTube
it's becoming more difficult to find my
content and there's a lot of content
that I cannot put on YouTube
unfortunately so to make sure you have
full access of all my information go to
drberg.com And subscribe to my
newsletter by clicking the link Down
Below in the description I will see you
on the other
side